citizens of the reject Nation it is time for the
Tim show Monarch Legacy of monsters episode what
what episode are we on I think we're on episode
eight doesn't matter it's in the title it's a
all righty guys well you know what I don't Hae
when you guys answer me this specific question
who would you rather have as a sibling Kate or
canaro leave it in the comments below and be
very descriptive as to why you would choose
one of them you have to choose yeah none of
this neither stuff anyway guys leave a like
that would be very much appreciated Roar that
subscribe notification Bell thanks to prepper for
helping us edit down these highlights full length
Reaction watch alongs where you syn up with
your own copy of Monarch Legacy of monsters
it's available for our super sexy rejects it's
over at our patreon page it's the best place
that's where John and Greg cover several shows
exclusively with highlights and watch alongs
included and I say let's just get our ciry
Clemens on let's do it do this Clemons let's
go you're just mad because he takes after me
of course I am it's not fair we Riot Russell's
POV he's obviously got your Brands and he'll be
blessed with my gravity defying breaking curveball
is this where the camera is I guess so look
your brains my arm It's the Best of Both Worlds
ah they're talking about their dad by their dad I
mean the present kid's dad their son kentaro and K
we we whoa he misses her so much damn that was
like the first romantic scene between her and
Andre's home she's got to be alive he seems
so downtrod I feel like she's alive if he's
got special you know ageless Juju je she must
too we've recently had some very promising
results with our gamma simulation techniques it
would appear so my hats off to you Captain we to
please so much scientific gibberish it might as
well be Chinese algebra on used it to cphon off
resources that ought to be used to safeguard
this great nation we are trying to safeguard
the world they think they're full of [__]
so you think that Godzilla respects National
boundaries our nuclear superiority proved more
than a match for Godzilla and I'm confident it
will again should need toise oh boy 2 years
since Castle Bravo you have provided not a
shred of evidence to suggest that possibility
damn dude and you haven't found Bigfoot either
I see one of your breakthroughs based on
technology developed by a former officer
in the Imperial Japanese Navy Dr meura here
ever qualified for a top secret clearan is
beyond me wow dude given the juicy tidbits
the FBI turned up and her background check
you son of a [__] what did they find we're
all in love with [Music] her welcome to Monarch
Tim Tim makes me feel like I'm in the TVA Tim
is the Mobius of Monarch your grandfather became
obsessed started pushing all these theories about
teleportation and wormholes real tinfoil Hat type
of stuff real [__] we're never going to
see Ever to get fitted for our temp4 hats
your freak flag fly bro Karo you got the best
lines fly that freak flag this is your legacy
this is more like it Legacy of the control room
Monarch has outposts all over the world right
now they are picking up gamma rapers just like
we saw before gday Alaska North Africa places
we know your father has been maybe he's leaving
all the gamma radiation is he predicting them
or is he following them good questions we do
qu questions really well around here but what
we need right now are some answers yeah oh my
God sh was talking to us meta we don't know
exactly what Shaw is trying to accomplish here
but if he sets off another blast it could push
it over the line so that means another GD I'd
rather not find out that's why you're here it
sounds like sha wants the monsters to conquer
uh-oh we need to know where Shaw's heading to
Next he dumped Us in the desert stole the
map and took off with your partner you saw
hoshi's map it let you to Godzilla Tim seems
to think that your bloodline gives you some
unique insight into the situation wow you're the
specials so I need you to think about your father
about this map that he made and about where it's
leading Shaw God what a long lens they chose for
this the bloodline yeah so they have some like
real special DNA with powers I've been telling
you man what exactly do you think we'll find
in there [Music] R whoa it won't be for the
faint of heart I can tell you that some traumatic
memories coming back I can't believe that crap he
said about you juicy tidbits what a load of racist
horeshit hey not bad dude how's your hand feel not
great well it's the first punch I've ever thrown
I need you guys to start making a map a map he
wants to know where the Titans are hiding let's
draw my goddamn map the map build me a case for
Monarch all those field notes and the journals
and the diaries that you've been keeping what we
know about the Titans where they where they sleep
what they eat spawn mate the whole shoting match
I want to know where eat I want to know where
they sleep going a little stir crazy in here or
I inherited that from someone with a temper keep
filling out uh maintenance request inherited that
from their grandpa July 7 2008 it was my 18th
birthday hey my dad was here doing a software
update on the geosynchronous Titan anomaly
sensing system gas yeah cheetas this was his
mission was it it was his life we're not going
to find him with some multispectrum satellite
sweep wait did you find something yeah at the top
of this box in the first page of this F operative
loss during field assignment and performance of
Duties missing presumed killed Koo okay Monarch
cost us our father and both our grandparents
wait missing presume killed she's alive she's
alive in the hollow Earth baby that's what I'm
thinking I'm thinking Hollow Earth living cuz
in the Godzilla xong tra there are people there
maybe she's involved with them that's racist John
cuz they're all Asians it was on hiroshi's map
places we're seeing a spike in Gamay admissions
yes one of it's where he lost her when we were in
the desert the way he talked about our grandmother
I thought he was going to tell me he was our
grandfather oh that's what we're all waiting
for Shaw is trying to rewrite the past to do that
he needs to go back to the place where everything
went to hell for him back to the streets we began
feeling as good as Monster Hunters can W go I am
not sending a bunch of untrained amateurs after
Lee Shaw they've been amazing you sent a bunch of
trained professionals last time how did that work
out for you oh you got to go against the grain we
can be your double agents I'll go with them
look they're randa's kids yeah we got found a
portfolio I mean that was me right screwed dad he
screwed us I understand if you need to leave I'm
not leaving but I'm not cleaning up his mess
I'm not doing this for him I'm just going to
stand here why do all their scenes sound the same
literally moments ago in the prove me wrong what
joke moments ago when they were all in the big
controller I was like I think I'm finally starting
to like this entire ensemble and then they stepped
into the hall and I was like God damn it this the
same exact kind of see you did dialog delivery
there is second third fourth hand accounts with
no corroborating EV sound CCH would you like
to lose the other hand they haven't fallen in
love yet right no they got their kiddo clearly CHS
are mission hatch and Pucket right so that's what
I did this is more like a blueprint of a house
that's designed by a hundred different Architects
are we ignoring the bugs you got stairways going
nowhere rooms with no doors and you end up with
a house that's bigger on the inside than on the
outside clean up after yourself H how' you manage
to get ants four stories underground there a sign
the hell was that bag I don't know beyond logic
lies the truth yes but hatch and Pucket can't see
the possibilities in the impossible the way you do
the way we do a Beyond logic lies my heart Billy
I'm thank you for what you did up there it was
stupid but thank you got my back look the nerve
that guy coming at you like that yeah but what
hatch said it wasn't the truth is there are things
in my life in my past that I haven't shared with
you I I don't care I don't care what you do from
the day that I met you when you wouldn't leave
me on the wreck of the laden I knew I knew that I
had to protect you that I could trust you and no
matter what John I think this is the part of the
timeline where they haven't done anything yet oh I
guess so keep up we started the episode with them
talking about Hiroshi so much going on I guess the
job here is to make it simple enough to understand
so that even uh Neanderthal could understand it
English please you're in the Philippines you can
eliminate the Siberian reports what no I had three
independent sources two drunk one blind next
okay uh you blurry photos photos nah he called
out blurry photos Monarch Legacy of Love Monarch
Legacy of adorability oh sh oh you getting bitter
dog you getting bitter very nice Borat has ruined
Kazakhstan yep Shaw escalated this yeah and he's
going to do it again if he sees you at least talk
to us what makes you think listen we are Roshi's
kids because he wants us here he wants someone to
take over the family business and he thinks we're
the only family he has left he's not can shoot us
it's okay you guys got this he'll listen to you I
think it'd be so funny if Kurt Russell just shot
them both right in the head I would have done it
sooner too but looks like you were right he's
already here I feel like the ending scene is
going to be the reveal that she's still alive I
could see that for sure to keep us hooked to con
in next week's episode oh dude spoilers I think
the final shot is going to be of whatever was in
that damn bag with the bugs in it y'all sure you
want to do this guess so I guess why not you know
what else are we going to do are they supposed
to be The Goonies yeah this is just a shot for
shot remake of The Goonies now cuz if they're
supposed to be The Goonies I never watch watch
The Goonies Yep this whole show has just been
a primer for your Goonies experience aren't you
[Music] excited oh the Reds what kind
of exposure are we looking at about 210
of a Miller is that bad bad adjacent
it's not good this place supposed to
be uninhabitable for Thousand Years monster
Chernobyl something's absorbing the radiation
ah a Gateway or someone they're Dad
yeah it's just shiroshi down there
just absorbing all sorts of radiation and
then vomiting into Kaiju mouths like a mama
bird don't move what is it what is it what
is it I'm not moving it's like molted oh no
that's it's a shelf yeah it's empty you're
fine shed its skin it's exoskeleton it's an
exoskeleton like when an insect MTS Tim just
learned what that was jeez Tim entomology
much gross please let's never see
them we're at six M SS now this is where they
lost Koo and this is where he'll be but where is
he [Music] oh sweet wowe jump yeah toss something
down there jump It's a portal it's an entry point
to where tinfoil Hatland and we didn't pack any
foil is Chara's plan really that crazy to try
and close it maybe he doesn't want to close it
maybe he wants to go in you think he's going to
go in he's going to go in after he better go
in charges settle around the perimeter looks
like look like have to bring this whole place
down CL yeah you're right can you diffuse them
you can try looks like they're rigged her radio
Detonator step away from the hey reunion it's me
Tim it's Tim shouldn't be here Tim you're not
cut out for field work sure about that maybe I
learned a thing or two from you a where's Shaw
you finally made it I've been waiting for you
this means you want to talk talk let's talk was
waiting back there till I heard your voice Kate
just you not hosi I mean not not canaro you know
what I mean all Asian people are the same stairs
to nowhere he's really not bothered by that book
we're on the stairs to Nowhere what the hell are
we missing stop missing with the ant [Music] whoa
[Music] ha figer on the inside the ants right the
Tardis I know how you are about your privacy you
can't be here oh no who's here the guy who's been
terrible monarchic person of course the ants
showed me it's bigger on the inside what are
you talking about what if they live underground
the Titans if that's how they move around the
world without being seen like ants yes gigantic
ants what if it's another realm not just beneath
the Earth but Hollow Earth yes inside but also
alongside oh existing together [Music] ooh mama
uh-oh this is my son hos oh so he adopted him I
guess so it's why I applied to do my postgraduate
work at Berkeley after the war I I wanted hero to
have other opportunities then I couldn't bring him
in the beginning jeez who's the father I just
didn't realize how long it was going to take
for me to bring him I was finally able to save up
enough money thanks to the jobat Monarch oh you
see how I'm treated a woman a Japanese what do you
think they'd do if they found out I was a widow
trying to raise a child alone oh boy then don't
do alone oh have shammer he seems really Gaga for
you why just me you know why you looked into his
eyes he's not just a Mindless destructive force
nope he knows what he's doing and what's that
protecting us there's a world down there Kate
and it's not ours A I know because I've been to
it you been to it flashback it exists Kate Billy
and KO were right please please believe me that's
how he aged slow or whatever what did you see tell
me what they couldn't believe it's really hard
to get to the hollow Earth though he's not here
to hurt us he's just keeping his kind in their
world and Us in ours so that's why you want to
seal off their world I am sealing off their world
but the sequels don't worry John this is a prequel
somewh no dude what makes you so sure that your
data whatever that might be is so right it's not
about the data cake it's all about belief oh hey
that is different than data I'm do before the Vice
President in about 2 minutes sadly there's nothing
in Lieutenant hatch's Illuminating report to
justify the continued funding of project Monarch
oh it's a map sir a comprehensive projection of
all the potential Titan threats currently under
assessment by project Monarch Jesus Christ you
did not give up sir I believe that you'll find
lieutenant hatch's report has omitted certain
facts to justify shifting funding from Monarch
to his own priorities oh such as Godzilla sir
that's highly classified why would he have
that in this file we didn't kill it oh boy I
just feel compelled to point out that this was not
provided by Lieutenant hatch but through the sole
dedication diligence and loyalty of doctors mea
and Randa absolutely I do hope that drir rand's
position as sole authority of a project monarch
scientific operations will remain unchallenged
and that hatch will be called a [__] he's lost
Michelle sha he doesn't know what he's doing he
knows exactly what he's doing and at least he's
not sitting around him waiting to see what happens
next all you people do is sit on your hands Koo
she was the first one to jump in against my better
judgment my mission was to protect her my mission
to protect you I know this is where you lost her
sounds like she was a force of nature this is to
make up for losing her isn't it well of course it
is smart kid clear the space oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy get out everybody out oh no oh God
they going fall in maybe he should have run this
by the team oh my God cor no but Kate loves her oh
[__] oh my God it's like a beetle [Music]
whoa oh no how did cor survive this I don't
know whoa everyone's going in jump on it kentaro
kentaro's like I don't want to go do I [Music]
go oh yeah damn was not the wrong we're both
wrong the ants were definitely more important
yeah it's good yeah man I like when ants find the
clues you have to follow the bug see where it goes
that's all you had to do and then it'll tell you
the answer to what you're looking for that's all
dad did he just watched bugs walk all over his
graphs and Maps he watched the ants oh no Kora you
fallen in what do I do to get you out I don't know
why dad was here I don't even want to go on this
adventure but I guess I will sha isn't there he's
going to blow it [Music] up so good right it's all
dude you're you could be in the in Monarch I could
have been in Monsters you could be in the show I'm
here to audition for Monarch Legacy of monsters
I'm going to play the sun really bent about my
dad I used to be an artist now I'm not anymore cuz
I didn't like the [__] and now I got my sister
who I hate but I follow around everywhere even
though all my dialogue is mostly about how I don't
want to do this I don't even want to be here just
want to go home to Japan with my mom who's one of
the best characters on the show that's a good
joke John thanks thank you the joke is good we
should remember that for the future I'm not here
to make jokes I just want to review the [Music]
episode take this seriously Greg I am me too what
you think of the episode I liked it I liked this
episode did you did you think it was the best
one we've had so far might be it's one of the
better ones best I don't know if it's the best
one but it's one of the good ones last one was
easily the best yeah that's true that's true I
mean the Tim episode is always going to reign
supreme but this could be like top four out of
eight so far this could be number four in the
top four out of eight I don't know I don't know
where I would rank it it's not as good as a Tim
episode episod but I like this episode and this
one uh you know I got a little maybe confused with
which point in time we were at in different parts
of the flashbacks but maybe maybe most definitely
I definitely got confused I says yeah I said to
you John well that first scene they're in the car
and they're like talking about they have a kid
and I was like no that's not it John but they're
talking about Hiroshi aren't they they're talking
about a kid of some kind yeah some random ass kids
but that was in Kurt Russell's flashback when he
was in the truck and then Michelle interrupted
his flashback that's right that's hey that's very
good attention to visual storytelling and we were
in the POV of him that's true in the flashback her
Russell wasn't in the room with them yeah in fact
I don't know whose POV flashback were watching
there I think we're just watching a flashback
just watching oh no wait he was watching them he
was he dropping on them sure in the yeah before
he comes out and is like Kate you talk to me yeah
yeah he's listening to all that he's just chilling
back there he's like waiting for the right queue
to come out he was touching himself you know love
story yeah and because they fell in love he
made aous decision and he's like I'm telling
the general about about how Godzilla's alive
because you don't love me and I'm mad at that
and I'm going to spitefully make sure that you and
Bill both are are elevated with me so that you can
never fully detach yourselves from me because I
did this this is going to get you killed now I
made the sacrifice that made Monarch what it is
she so alive the show could not be more obvious
she's very much alive she's coming back I would
be more surprised if she's not alive she won't
have aged a day I don't think she's aged no how
long were they in Hollow Earth for how' they get
to Hollow Earth I don't know I mean she got a lot
of question I have cuz I thought Hollow Earth was
like this really difficult thing to Traverse
to get into and like are they going against
the rules in Godzilla I didn't think you could
just fall into it well I wonder if we see K get
taken away by that like pile of roached things
so I don't know maybe like they shielded her
from whatever boundaries there are I don't know I
don't and I don't know how that would account for
Shaw getting through or coming back or coming
back yeah I don't understand any of this John
none of it makes any sense and it won't the show's
over it's done it's the last do so what was your
favorite part about it my favorite part about it
uh Tim always good Tim uh I liked the scenes in
the past especially between Anders Holm and the
actress who plays K right liked uh their little
intimate scenes together we've gotten a lot of the
shaw perspective on that romance triangle and this
episode was one I think the first one that really
focused on Randa and K uh uh miora having romantic
chemistry together so yeah I liked all those
sweet little moments and even though it's a you
know it's a vers of the you know poking a pencil
to the paper thing like I thought the ants were
fun like you know that something's going to come
out of that and I thought that was fun um I guess
that was my my favorite aspect of the episode and
then I mean seeing them I I did you know being at
Monarch being with you know everybody trying to
figure all this stuff out you know when you have
our main characters in that environment I I was
with it I was enjoying it there really just that
one scene where they go back into the hallway
where Kate and canaro talking the hallway and I
was like oh yeah this is the stuff I don't like
about this show but the rest of it was was all
pretty engaging pretty fun and uh and yeah this
was one that felt like Monsters and Titans are
looming even though you don't see tons of them you
do get the one at the end but even like with the
moled husks the exoskeletons and stuff all that
was neat it's pretty cool what was your favorite
aspect of the episode Greg uh all the stuff that
you said that was your favorite was easily my
favorite hey I still find the 50s flashbacks the
most compelling absolutely um yeah I mean I am so
absorbed into the monster verse as it is that the
immediacy of the journey is kind of just rais this
one was one of those episodes where connectivity
raised questions for me and I found myself a
little distracted by that sure cuz I'm like well
all this stuff about like sealing off Hollow Earth
and consequences of that well I'm fully aware
that we just we have a big big movie incoming
yeah he's kind of like um he's like Shaw's kind
of like the reversal of Vera forga from don't
yawn hold it never yawn during your monologue G
hold it in hold it in I drive to the top of the
Laurel Kanye mountain and yawn before you show up
to make sure I got that out of my system and no
one is in sight and then I drive back here that's
why I'm like I'm running a little bit behind cuz I
had to go yawn someplace go to the furthest point
respectful to the highest peak you don't think I
want to Y look how tired I look I can barely keep
my eyes open on camera you're perpetually tired
wow that's rude Oh I thought you were going to
say I was racist that's rude it's also rude it's
not racist good Asian people are always WI awake
yes so what's your excuse or at least what's half
of your excuse anyway John yeah or should I say
ywn that was a good one got there puns he's the
inverse of Vera fora yeah Vera fora is like I want
all the tit End To Rule and Reign and I think we
could live a much better life that way cuz I'm
smart and I definitely know what's best for my
child yeah and instead of keeping them in their
world and Us in ours let's just let's just let
them have all of it and and Shaw is Kurt Russell's
a rather compelling character is this man who you
know he's he's always like Mr carismatic guy but
underneath all that Charisma is a lot of pain of
loss of Bill loss of Kiko KO Koo loss of Koo and
you know uh decisions that were made consequences
and he he he lives with all that and now he's
trying to make amends he's atoning he's on a path
of of atonement but is this path of atonement the
right choice you know or is he being clouded by
his own personal feelings so I think there's a lot
of very interesting character stuff that they're
doing with him absolutely um yeah I mean look we
can't go a video without mentioning I think Kaden
and T still two very boring characters man like
what the hell happened with them in this episode
yeah you know Kate scene where Kurt Russell's
good but who's the interesting character there
Kurt Russell Russell I mean Kurt Kurt Russell's
there to be like yeah I looked at Godzilla in the
eyes yes he saw me and I saw him and she steps in
to be like there will be no murder today yeah that
because I am embracing my character Arc I think is
what is I'm accepting of my legacy I really wanted
some catharsis from that moment I don't know
what my role is exactly yeah something about
my blood and Monarch and I really wish that would
pay off so that we could get you guys more vitally
involved in this plot I kind of like them back
and forth thing in the truck about like he's not
going to shoot us he wants us here I thought that
was okay that was when I was like he's not going
to shoot us that's the one time Cano's dejected
same delivery seems purposeful yes true agree
and I mean this was perhaps I mean Kurt Russell
has always been like good but this was an episode
where I was like oh okay I could feel like the
the how the old how the the you know 50s version
of you became this guy I could feel the history
here yeah um but I think in terms of getting
distracted by connectivity I was like I'm not not
really sure what I still am waiting for this show
to be like all right you've really contributed
something to the World building yeah something
fresh and vital and and important that'll come
up in Godzilla XCOM like look how Apex came to
be yeah I was really really scratching at the dog
how this happen how is there an apex who would
come up with a company that makes Tech like that
what it's not possible really need to know got
to know and terms of Hollow Earth stuff uh yeah
it's if anything what they what the show's Mor
I think the show's done really well in terms of
connectivity is the most subtle thing they've done
is how how much they have recontextualized John
Goodman's character yeah true who just gets like
funly off in Kong Skull Island yeah yeah the guy
who gets killed at one I try to forget about that
stuff just going to die I know he's just going to
have a death scene you know hey maybe this will if
you took everything you see in this show put it
in Timeline order leading to that scene where he
dies you be like man that's how he goes man what
a bummer wow how unceremonious that unceremonious
death they gave this guy but anyway yeah that's
just that um about think life is though that is
how life is and if there's one thing this mon show
does is life um so there's that and uh K C Clemens
is fine I don't understand this thing about their
blood and connect they keep talking about it blood
Juju I think I think they're more like a good
luck coin that Tim carries around with him I
didn't want to say fortune cookie cu that would
have sound very racist sure that actually would
have sounded racist yes even though that was just
the metaphor I was looking for um it would have
sounded racist if I said good luck fortune cookie
that's true good thing that you acknowledged that
good thing I acknowledge it thus thwarting racism
another day yeah I did I beat it um but it it is
they are just kind of like a goodlook um token
to keep around you know yeah because they don't
really do anything other than hey I stumbled
upon this piece of information that was just
right here in front of me wow for people who look
at their data and then re recheck their data all
the time like you would think that they would be
great at catching stuff like this just there' be
like these Rand kids are the key yes they got
special Rando blood they know stuff that we
don't know they're uncovering things they got some
special connection to all this their Monarch blood
it's about belief now it's not about science
anymore John we've entered the territory of
spiritualism with the monsters it's all the
above they're going to worship Godzilla in the
next one uh so yeah there's that I mean I think
this was a I I probably ranked this as like the
third or fourth best honestly I would agree you
said this was the best I didn't I did I said it
was the absolute best he said it was the best
I said it was one of the best said not better
than Tim and you're like well not better than
Tim I said one of I didn't say it was the bad I
definitely did not say it was the bad you said it
was better than every episode and all the reacher
episodes I definitely said that this happens when
someone is forced to yes and a you can't get them
to ever grow a back you know Screw you buddy I
said no such thing they don't defend themselves
yes and I'm going to re-edit the the part where
I said one of the best into this after this point
so that people know face facts Tim you you I the
Tim of the real you CED it away you are the Tim
of the real rejects yeah I'm not fori I'm the
canaro and Kate and uhz I just want way better
character than either of them combined no no
but you are the chosen one I guess no all I do
is whine and speak dry you're Koo yeah man no Koo
she's wonderful oh yeah it was koo's uh husband
who's the real father the real bloodline Dad it's
not in the dad jeans we keep looking at the dad's
DNA it's all in the mom oh my God Monarch's woke
Mother Earth mother nature mother Titan Monarch
mother of Legacy Legacy of Mother's momark Legacy
of M Legacy of mommies Legacy of mommies oh God
that's really where the legacy is we keep looking
at the male DNA yeah but that's why we're going
from Grandma to Kate the greatest characters yeah
from Kate Kate to Kate Kate gotta love Kate gotta
love her gotta love Kate you know we've over this
we don't need to go over it again been over this'
been over this they're boring they they really
are they don't live up to their grandmother they
don't exceptionally far more interesting character
and when they try to assert themselves into like
operations where people have guns and stuff
like that I'm always like I feel like I'm in
the middle of some kind of what is their Ling
experiment what are they rising to tell me sh
what what is have they've been rejecting their
their Destiny their lineage their their place in
the world of Monarch yes have they been lost and
I don't know where I belong yes what is there what
is it that they are arcing into cuz I'll tell
you it's right now it is an empty vessel to me
they're arcing from normal people to people who
go on adventures John a real Arc Baby John please
don't mock me I would never I'm asking a genuine
question to the camera mock art and I'm expecting
an answer any moment now okay I'll be quiet I'll
be quiet just in case we don't want to miss it
you don't think I want to yawn you don't think
I want to yawn you can get the biggest yawn out
at the very end of this you don't think I want
to yawn you don't think I've been sitting here
dozing off for the last 45 minutes how DiCaprio
would do it I want to [__] ya for the past 40
minutes I've been here trying to pay attention to
this show about this brother sister Asian Dynamic
and you don't think I want to yawn I'm yawning
in my head all through this conversation slipped
a little wallberg there but what's like to see I
want Leo in the show now I'm intense yeah I'm do
do the squinty Le the dumb Dum D sou guy bubling
guy who gets overwhelmed sometimes and I start to
yell yeah those is the two best Leo Leo types the
Leo the Leo the range of Leo yeah man Southern
leading man in control with power or stupid
southern guy yeah yeah yeah gets used in taking
advantage of yeah and then it all coalesces into
Calvin candy where he's both he both characters
is he really a man of power there or is he also
kind of a joke John oh both both to your point
yes and but but no they're important they're
arcing they're people I gave this episode a
6.9 out of 10 sure seven I'll give it I'll give
an extra 0.1 go to seven yeah I felt bad for Tim
and Michelle or whatever yeah I think it was I
think it was nowhere near his ENT I think like
you get more of the monster verse no I think
the last one's more monster verse still yeah
you get the tie in Apex and how that came to be
and and how Monarch came from the Shadows into
the light yeah to how a podcast would one day be
formed that should be the closing shot this of
Brian Ty when they're like hey Brian Ty Henry's
character name and you're like and then he turns
around and you see his face and he's like I want
to start a podcast at Apex let people know smash
to play smash the black yeah dude I love it I
love it and now we have the connective tissue
between king of the monsters and Godzilla versus
Kong uh I needed yeah I I think um it's good it's
good plot mechanics man this should have been a
b show I'm just saying I don't think this should
have been a B I don't think it should have been
a week to week show I don't even love I don't
even like to say that about stuff but this does
feel like it would probably be more satisfying it
would 100% be more satisfying as a binge and
uh cuz yeah I mean like this kind of episode
was uh is cool little tidbits of information
really serious but I I did prefer the flavor
of last episode a lot more I was like oh my God
we're on the up up yeah we're crusting into the
crescendo to end the season ending off with the
bang I love just how they other than last episode
how they'll do this like one second tidbit of
a monster every time yeah yeah it just put one
at the very end it often feels like Apple Studio
note or legendary being like we got to do it we
got to there's some produ that's the producer's
contribution whoever that producer was on set it
was like um you know I think we need a monster in
here to make audiences think this is a show about
monsters you know maybe I don't know it might be
a valuable asset to our monster show it it's not
even about like the monsters within here Humanity
why is it called Legacy of monsters it's just
about how Monarch um that would be a compelling
debate but the story of how Monarch came to be
if you really think about it is so basic it is
it is a very basic story oh we discovered some
Titans we formed a little military group someone
in the military at one point wasn't a big fan of
it tried shutting it down but now some evidence
we found some evidence and we kept the operation
going and they flirt with the idea that like
oh maybe they are monsters of humanity cuz
like oh this hbomb didn't work we're going to
build even bigger hbomb that's kind of it and
they're like look how Wolverine found his jacket
you know yeah dude that's what a lot of a lot of
it is that's that's how I feel about so much
of what we learned I don't like things where
I don't know every circumstance of how they came
to be you know I'm so back and forth in this show
what do you mean I mean John Legacy of yawns
as we've talked about it and I thought about
this episode a little more I was like I think I
liked it a little less than I think I did oh are
you offended I am good because yeah I'm so sad I'm
really just so back and forth on on this show yeah
CU you can just constantly see all the potential
cuz cuz they have so many good assets organized
and the writing is it is it is so is veryy by the
numbers of how everything is even in the 50s story
which I still find to be way more intriguing it's
pretty basic when you think about it of how it all
goes down it's just significantly better it's
all that mindbending like I was talking uh on
the on the podcast I with heavy spoilers I was
just Point got brought up I was talking about
director's cuts and how sometimes a director's
cut can be manipulative because a theatrical
version can be so bad and a director's cut can
be better and it can naturally make your mind
go oh this movie is now good only because it's
better sure right like Rebel moon will be like
the rebel Moon director yeah once both parts
once both parts that have been hacked down he
said Zach Zack SN said the director's cut feels
totally different and so I'm like did he I don't
understand why you released whatever we don't need
we don't need to dive into that John that's all a
story for another day that I'm looking forward
to having with Zack snd fans yes so too the now
I'm not and I think the 50 story genuinely
has some really great stuff in there yeah I
think that when you pull back and and look at it
you're like but there's not really anything that
like I don't know it's just it feels very by the
numbers when you think about it yeah there's just
not as much to it I keep coming back to the JJ
Abrams Mystery Box thing and I know that there
are good examples of him executing that but
it does feel like that to me where it's like
they create this air of mystery and they create
these obstacles and stuff and she even says this
at one point in this episode was like we're good
got questions we're good questions and I don't
even feel like we have that many questions I
feel like the show could have been like four
episodes it does feel like that it feels like
it's been stretched out I feel like we're watch
you know when they would do like viral videos
they would shoot like extended viral videos
to expand on like they would do that for they
a lot like Prometheus and alien Covenant yeah
like there's a whole scene with James Franco
that exists for an alien Covenant viral video
that is not in the movie that's kind of what
I feel like we're watching here just a super
long version of that sure this could have been
we episodes or something like that yeah it feels
like some that's what I feel like we're watching
a very long version of that where occasionally
the episode comes along with like that that was
really like the last episode I iode really did
it for me I really liked that last episode a lot
and this one just kind of brought me back to yeah
it's fine the the last episode was was fun in a
different way and dramatic in a way that coalesced
properly ly whereas an episode like this I think
wants to have more of a somber tone because of
you know this the the struggles being presented
and the truths being revealed about like oh K's
got this kid and she's a widow and blah blah uh
and and it only in some of those flashback scenes
it gets close but I feel like in an episode
where they want to go more downtrodden and
more burdened by all these things they're not
as good at that like when they do go towards
fun it works better because so partly this
should be fun to some extent but uh it's not
I it's not that I want this to be deep but it
doesn't feel like there's an appropriate amount
of depth to what they're trying to do much of
the time no and it doesn't have to again it
can it would be more intriguing if they were like
10-minute videos that left you Desiring ooh they
should make a series yeah where like I I and then
they make the series and you go they should have
just thought this as a viral video yeah as web
episodes it's like I would like to at least walk
out of these with that feeling of like damn I got
I got a I got so many question like that's that's
why we end up talking for so long because we keep
trying to find the good cuz it's us and you know
like we like unless we're like doing a straight
out of the theater movie review where we're like
we're on a time crunch here we got to be blunt
we got to be blunt we got no choice we got to be
blunt because we are getting kicked out of here
soon with these we talk forever here because we
spend the first like 15 minutes trying to be like
nice and then as we keep going we start realizing
you know what maybe we didn't like it as much as
we think we do I just wish this show had better
writing I don't know it's weird and with all the
all the credits they have on it's not weird it's
a perfectly reasonable ass John Yeah well yeah
and like for for the for for what this is I don't
think it's that you have people like Matt fraction
and Matt shackman involved and I get Matt shackman
is more on the film side fraction more on the
comic book side but like those are people who
seem like perfect to help Shepherd something
like this along with whoever else they have
assembled it's so fascinating to me that that
yeah like it's just fun and intriguing enough
to where like I do find stuff I enjoy about it
each time keep saying the word fun and I don't
understand how you you say that word so often and
I I'm just not there with you I on that adjective
specifically it's not that I think the show itself
is very fun say it's fun enough it's fun I'm like
I still have fun I'm like you have fun I have
to like be like keep paying attention cuz I am
I'm not as invested as I I would like to check my
phone sure I'm beused I I don't think the show is
is all that fun itself for what it is doing uh I
that's just me being like I I'm happy to be here
watching a Godzilla thing even if it's not not a
great Godzilla thing you know like it's it's fun
enough and by that I mean it's not aggravating at
least most of the time uh no it's a very passive
show NE it's fun in the sense that it's neat
I'm always like oh cool like I'm always here
for the setup and I always feel like whether or
not they'll deliver the punchline or the payoff
you know is is way hit or miss but I'm always
slightly bemused by what we're here to do we're
walking dead got to in later Seasons I feel like
we got here by episode like three God but I would
so kill for like more random scenes of let's
just pair these two off and make them talk for
a minute let's pair these two off and make them
talk for a minute like I I'll take that cuz like
I I don't know like this one of these episodes is
interesting because this episode is more action
oriented uh than some of the other ones uh what
do you mean action oriented well you know you're
on both timelines and people are moving around a
lot and it's like oh I got to you know we we got
to run across the world to Kazakhstan and we got
to go to Monarch and we got to go find Sha and
then in the past it's like oh you know randa's got
to run over here to Kay's place and then they got
to talk from it and then Shaw's got to run over
to the military guy and it's like we're doing a
lot we're doing a lot of stuff in an episode
like this uh and I mean it did have at least
one or two nice emotional beats but I feel like
you trade one for the other you either trade for
an episode where it's like all right we're going
to have a bunch of Dow repetitive scenes of these
two kids not agreeing about how to proceed on
this adventure or we're going to do one of these
where you know we're doing a bunch and we're going
all sorts of places and then the impact is maybe
lesser because all right look man it's late and
I got to keep editing we will never fully Artic
I got to go listen uh guys what do you think about
this episode would you rather have canaro or Kate
as your sister or brother I don't think I forgot
about that yeah buddy and uh listen we'll talk
with everyone uh really really soon uh thank you
very much uh bye last two episodes are going to be
great all right John pick a name hey how about
male Lyon M Lyon my goodness man you know what
I imagine you got for Christmas this year a
special Jewish surprise from the h bear now I
know you probably haven't heard about the Hanukkah
Bear right been deprived if you've been following
some of these shout outs you might know about
the Hanukkah bear so the Hanukkah bear uh you
know Santa goes to the chimney Hanukkah bear he
goes to your trash yes H he goes you know like you
might leave it out once a week for people I don't
know how it works in Sweden maybe you guys just
like throw things out into the street and then
it just magically disappears you know why imine
disappears that Hanukkah bear is going around town
just eating up all the trash man and uh I hope the
hanuk ver left you some great presents every night
uh day one because there's eight days in hukah uh
left you a big turd and day two uh left you like
a hairball or something coughed up yeah then day
three a $100 bill can you believe it and then day
four big pile of piss and day five other little
bears because Hanukkah bear is a m female and
didn't want to you know take care of any of these
bears and so now they're yours so now they're
yours to take care of but once they get to a
certain age they will Rebel and murder you so you
better get rid of them fast true and then on day
six I gave you a James Bond collection CU we got
to throw in in there CU and then day seven they
gave you the new actor who's playing James Bond
shows up right at your doorstep congratulations
you get to meet Finn wolfard the new James
Bond and then day eight this the new Indiana
Jones reboot comes out just for you cuz he loves
Indiana Jones as well and he was uh is that the
day eight yeah the day eight of Dy that's better
than I was going to the day eight of Destiny
baby you're going to have so much Cinema and and
bodily fluids to deal with on Christmas I was on
Ra was going up that hill man I was about to just
make a climax about to mic drop this [__] about
to do the flags of our father's little all four
soldiers planting the American flag right there
type of statue it's about to do Rocky climb to
the top of the stairs fist pump in the air if I
Only Could Make a Deal With God I'd get him to go
back 10 seconds that you could do all that yeah I
had a great great final one to give to male and
now he's never going to know well how about day
nine let's let's add a day nine not day nine
it's not how Hanukah bear Works say just Willy
Dilly add a day to the Hanukkah bear schedule
yeah that's true I I know I'm just bargaining
I can't accept reality M but maybe you can he M
thanks for being here Budd we love [Music] okay